what's up everybody happy friday time
for gratitude journal live stream number
35 i have a special guest with me in the
house will be joining us shortly sharing
three things that we're grateful for we
do this daily we do this consistently
because mentally sound happy
entrepreneurs make for better
entrepreneurs go make a big difference
in the world and then the other
important thing is that you asked
yourself why go one level deeper every
time ask yourself why you're so grateful
for these things because that's what's
going to really make the difference so
i'm going to share three things did i'm
grateful for my guests will share three
things you guys will share three things
in a live chat did you watch it
afterwards leave comments below may be
consistent don't just watch the video
you gotta participate if you want to
feel the benefits so i'm gonna go first
I'm grateful for I uncle for Philippe
Philippe is an instructor at tribal
dance salsa he he's mainly our kizomba
instructor but he's training to become a
salsa instructor with us as well he came
over last night as part of our my
anniversary with Nina and gave us a
kizomba lesson Nina wanted to improve
for kizomba skills so Philippe surprised
showed up and I made me to open the door
and she's like what is going on and he
didn't charge me for it either which was
super nice if he wanted to be our his
anniversary present toss or was happy to
pay him and it was it was fun it was a
good hour plus a good times good to
learn some new skills improve my kizomba
dancing and super grateful for that part
of last night I next I'm difficult for
this restaurant called Mustafa's the
next thing that we did was we went to
this turkish restaurant called mustafa
that specializes in turkish pizza and
that the inside of their place is AK
and so feel like you're walking into a
cave when you go into the restaurant
just a totally different experience in
what you're normally used to going into
a right to the restaurant and so super
grateful for that different experience
as well Nina loves trying new food it's
one of her things that she loves the
most and on their menu was a sampler
pizza that had all other pizzas combined
into one pizza we're basically every
slice of this pizza is a different type
of pizza so she ordered that it was good
super filling fun times um other number
3 i'm i'm grateful for my my co-host on
the league of legends channel rashid cup
TV marisha Rodriguez getting getting
better it's been awesome to see her
progress already we've done I forget how
many episodes of this league of legends
live stream now but watching her her
progress and confidence and fun coming
out and answering the questions and
giving feedback and providing valued
entrepreneurs was been awesome to see
the growth and I'm excited to see where
where she takes from here so those are
my three let's bring on our special
guest who's going to share his three let
me tilt the camera mr. J reyez is in the
house yo yo what you got man three
things all right I am grateful for easy
energized awakenings like in the morning
when I get up I know there's a huge
chunk of the world that has some issues
in the morning I don't I love waking up
and I'm so happy it's easy and
energizing and simple against my day
going I'm grateful for fulfilling
collaborations anytime I'm teaming up
with someone awesome someone creative
someone bold experimental you know an
empire building 0 I love it I love
fulfilling collaborations and I'm
thankful for
high heels hi what high heels they are
the sexiest shoe man my heel I heroes
tell me you see a chicken on heels or
you are not like that is gorgeous I
[ __ ] love it high kick you know why I
think it's cuz you put the eye I put the
emphasis on the heels high heels high
heels high heels I'm interesting I like
that different all right there we go
three things so let's get to you guys in
the live chat what are you grateful for
today papadum we're getting some shout
outs we got my bill kicking us off 35
minutes ago he was here early ready to
get going Xena was people for number one
the great amount of feedback I got on my
upcoming video i want to see so i want
to see this video's a now i want to give
some feedback i'll see if you seen it
you've seen it is a now feel left out
bro i want to see this video there are
lots of things you left there I'm not
left that there are lots of things to
change or at least try out but it's for
the better i love that number to a
breakup can be emotionally draining and
usually it isn't something enjoyable but
today it is okay me and my headache just
broke up yay I like that that's been a
persistent headache therefore Z though
I'm glad that's gone man it's awesome
where's number 33 yesterday's live
stream it was a lot of fun and I missed
watching that many live streams on one
day yeah we had some good interesting
interviews yesterday the first the first
one was nuts and then we went off on a
whole bunch of different tangents
talking different entrepreneurs I had a
lot of fun yesterday too and thank you
for joining me in all of those anal that
was good millerville grateful for
persistence and tenacity I like that que
el bien all caps good morning everyone
Wow good morning talk about what if it
was your first point energizing wake up
something like that I like that look at
that good morning kale bean is energized
we made it to orlando all right congrats
super happy about that and is grateful
for continental
breakfast nice the ease of a maid for
you breakfast instead I hadn't get up
and do it yourself also grateful for a
nice gentleman named Hakeem who helped
us in a in various ways yesterday I like
that and for the Ducks walking around me
asking for food I love that that's cool
man congrats on getting there Evan
although you may not know how you played
a crucial role in reaching this goal
thank you for this live gratitude stream
I love that I'm glad we could play a
small part in that it's awesome that
you're there you guys a bunch of banter
what do we got vacation more docs a lot
of a lot of talk about the Ducks no I
did not help the Ducks get there to
astor food we have no way of getting
here but being grateful every day has
changed my attitude to one of endless
possibilities I like that I wondered
that it won again so he wrote we had no
way of getting here because he's from a
blues from Dominican one either Orlando
we had no way of getting here but being
grateful every day has changed our
attitude to one of endless possibilities
powerful telling you guys you got to
keep it up it works what else the Ducks
the endless possibilities to the docks
manjunath hi everybody welcome Rishi
couple of everyone and welcome hashtag
cup of ducks Wow the duck theme is is
the duck theme is rampant today mmm
thunderclap hashtag thunderclap nakiri
would hi family hashtag leave nation
welcome back manjunath I'm today and
people for really small things like pens
electricity and mobile phones
electricity is super important what else
Rishi has been to a cave restaurant
that's pretty good I like that the curio
grateful for little ones I coach now for
my women mentees for my mentors Evan
you're one of them bless you heart thank
you for that really appreciate that
what else what else what else what else
Marvel things high heels are hot high
heels high heels are hot I like this
sweat top hello everyone I hope you
havin a good day welcome sweat that
Canadian heat Canada heels are American
heels pronunciation what jay is Canadian
too I mean he's a citizen of the world
but you still Canadians we're both
Canadian what else what else what else
new future builder due to the mention of
breakfast I'm people for pancakes french
toast eggs bacon and good sear Wow new
future bill that goes goes overboard
with five things to be grateful for
breakfast wise I like it what else what
else what else you guys have a lot of a
lot of chat happening I like a cherry
cream for my garage heater it's snowing
in parts of Ontario yesterday that was
crazy we're gonna need the heaters
busting out soon Busta nut soon a
sweater it's Diwali time in India so I
wish for brightness and everyone's life
very cool thank you for that I'm wish
for brightness in your life too i love
that is it nine ten it's nine ten nine
ten guys we're gonna head off to twitch
play our league of legends with rishi
kept evng rise and we're probably going
to do a crazy experiment that we haven't
done before so it might work out
fantastically it might just totally bomb
so let's see what happens see you guys
there if not have an awesome friday
close you weak strong we believe in you
i hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love we'll see you soon